hot breath uh question i always like to
ask comedians on here since we're on the
lows
is i always ask comedians about like an
epic bomb
that they've had whether it's like a
story of getting booed on stage or just
something you'll never forget there's
just epic failure epic
bombs i mean there's one i've told a
bunch is like
i did i used to work the door at this
club called broadway comedy club and i
uh
i've been there yeah uh it's uh
i just was getting heckled real bad and
um
this guy like we went back and forth a
couple of times and i had and i remember
he was like making fun of my pants and i
was like
and they were like shitty pants but it
was like it's
such a hack look at your pants oh that
was his line i was like yeah
yeah they're probably bad but we went
back and forth one time like and he
said a couple things that like triggered
me and i and i said something that must
have really triggered him i guess i said
something i was like yeah you're [__]
garbage i said something like you're a
garbage person or something
and that just set him off and he got up
any any and all i heard when he got what
got up was like
and i was like oh [__] i knew he's gonna
spit on me
oh and he tried to get to the stage and
the waitresses all like me there because
i worked the door so they were kind of
barricading the stage
and he i just heard and it just it's
right on my shirt
you know and uh like terrible people
have the best dame you know
and he hit me right he hit me right in
the chest and i guess it could have been
worse right
but from that distance it was still
impressive to make contact with the spit
and uh yeah and then he and his
girlfriend she was
humiliated i could tell but he was
waiting
i'm gonna wait outside for you he was so
worked up and
uh this guy chris murphy was like i'll
walk you outside
and he was like i mean we'd weaker than
me and chris murphy can't do [__]
he's like it looks like he's a joke
about looking like a like a he's a
redhead he's a joke about looking like a
pencil
in his hair is the eraser or something
and it's like i'm like that's that's my
muscle
that's who's coming with me uh but he
but he was
brave enough to come out with me and he
made sure i got home okay he's a nice
guy he's always been a
good dude how long into your career was
that
i don't know that must have been like
[Music]
at least eight years no maybe 10 years
ago oh 10 years ago
oh yeah that was a while ago but uh
yeah i i definitely didn't handle it i
go the worst ones you look back and like
why don't you even handle it well
yeah but you never know until after in
the moment you're just like straight
survival mode
yeah with a crowd i remember i tried to
go back in the material after he spat on
me and i was like well that's not
happening
you know i remember they they were like
uh they were shaking they were scared
for me and i think they
once they pity you there's no turning it
around like they they pitied me
you know they they uh
i heard a woman like go like oh
yeah there's no there's no turning that
around
yeah there were so many awes in that set
like such a lost boy
and uh they just yeah once they just
once they're in that mind state there's
no coming back
when you start in new york too right
yeah that's where you started coming
yeah
so i mean that's pretty new york is
that's the mecca of comedy so the fact
you get to start there that probably has
to forge your funny even faster
yeah it's weird i guess it goes both
ways because you do but also like
it's there's enough room that you can
kind of
i guess you could get good quickly but i
feel like it took me a while to get
noticed
which is a good thing you know like it
took me a while to
become who i wanted to be on stage and
like you know i'm still it's still work
in progress you still want to improve
but
uh yeah when you start people
see you and they're like oh he's they
could see him be like he's not funny and
they've made
their mind up on you yeah or they could
see you and be like
oh he's been here for a while he's paid
his dues so it works both ways you know
like but then there's those people like
hannibal burst who just come to new york
with this heat and they're already
really funny and
and they're so so it could work both
ways